buenos días las negociaciones están
estancadas en estos tres puntos
fundamentales el acuerdo está negociado
en su mayoría hace rato hace varios
meses pero estos tres puntos han evitado
que se llegue al acuerdo
recordemos básicamente sobre los
derechos de pesca que se ha convertido
en un símbolo para el primer ministro y
para darles una idea de lo importante y
lo simbólico que resultan es que en el
2016 este fondo de las banderas de los
motivos para el referendo para salir de
la unión europea así que estos líderes
hoy es el presidente de la comisión
europea y el primer ministro boris
johnson hablarán sobre el mediodía -hora
local- para tratar de revisar si desde
el miércoles ha habido un avance lo
suficientemente importante que les
permita creer que habrá humo blanco al
final o finalmente no entonces tendrían
que seguir las negociaciones pero no se
sabe hasta cuándo
dado que el 31 de diciembre como
mencionas es la fecha límite y el
acuerdo debe ser ratificado por los
parlamentos tanto británicos como de la
unión europea
se prevé que de no lograr un acuerdo los
diálogos se extiendan en este caso que
sigue luís a
podrían extenderse por supuesto podría
seguir por una semana más o hasta más
allá del 31 de diciembre de este año es
decir seguirían en el 2021 lo que sería
catastrófico para el primer ministro
boris johnson quien fue elegido
recordemos para sacar al reino unido-
definitivamente de la unión europea ahí
la complejidad veremos y boris johnson
decide entonces que es hora de anteponer
sus intereses personales más allá de los
intereses del país así que es una
conversación bien bien importante porque
lo que está en juego es bien complejo no
solamente estaría implicando las dos
economías tanto de la unión europea como
del reino unido- sino una crisis que
podría haberse en este país en las
fronteras a lo largo y ancho del canal
de la mancha a partir del primero de
enero porque toda la comida
prácticamente que llega al reino unido-
viene de productos de la unión europea
así que de ahí la complejidad